y
[Música]
la variante omicron sigue su expansión
por el mundo ya se registró un primer
caso en francia metropolitana
mientras que eeuu se exigirá a partir
del próximo lunes a todos los viajeros
un test negativo de coronavirus mientras
tanto la unión europea contemple la
posibilidad de vacunación obligatoria
para todos sus ciudadanos
la organización de naciones unidas
advierte del nuevo récord de necesitados
para el año 2022 se calcula que unas
274 millones de personas en todo el
mundo
requerirán de ayuda de emergencia debido
a la pandemia los conflictos y el cambio
climático
sigue la polémica en torno al paradero
de la tenista china peng shuai el comité
olímpico internacional anunció que
mantuvo una nueva videollamada con la
deportista en tanto que la asociación
femenina de tenis la w canceló todos sus
eventos en el gigante asiático en medio
de preocupaciones por la seguridad de la
jugadora varias personalidades del
deporte apoyaron la medida
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se redoblan co y
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos con la pandemia de
coronavirus y la nueva variante omicron
eeuu exigirá a partir del próximo lunes
a todos los viajeros que se trasladen a
su territorio que presenten un test
negativo de kobe 19 tomado 24 horas
antes de su vuelo
independientemente de su estado de
vacunación o país de salida en francia
luego detectarse el primer caso de dos
micro nena isla de la reunión se reportó
un primer contagio en la variante en
francia metropolitana por otro lado
japón retrocede en sus restricciones de
viaje por omicron un día después de
ordenar a las aerolíneas suspender las
reservas de vuelos internacionales por
un mes el gobierno nipón relajó entonces
la medida para así permitir el retorno
de los nacionales ante la aparición de
esta nueva variante de coronavirus debe
ser obligatoria las vacunas contra el
kobe 19 la presidenta de la comisión
europea usura von der layen afirma que
el tema debe ser objeto de debate
es una cuestión que se plantea en todo
el continente deben los países de la
unión europea hacer obligatorias las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 mientras la
variante omicron se extiende por europa
austria y alemania se han mostrado
favorables a la obligatoriedad la
comisión europea dijo el miércoles que
los países deberían estar abiertos al
debate
av
a ver cómo podemos fomentar y pensar
potencialmente en la vacunación
obligatoria dentro de la unión europea
esto necesita un debate esto necesita un
enfoque común pero es una discusión que
creo que tiene que ser dirigida a cinco
civiles en francia las tasas de
vacunación son altas en torno al 75 por
ciento aunque 6 millones de personas aún
no se han vacunado algunos expertos
sostienen que lo importante no es
centrarse en obligar sino en convencer a
la gente de que se vacune en primer
lugar
báscolo visitado lo importante es
convencer a las personas de que se
vacunen lo antes posible ya sea la
primera la segunda o la tercera dosis de
luz
cada país de la unión europea ha
adoptado una postura diferente respecto
a la implantación de la vacuna el
secretario de sanidad del reino unido
dijo la semana pasada que no cree que
vayan a hacer obligatorias las vacunas
mientras que grecia es el primer país
que especifica un límite de edad con un
mandato para los mayores de 60 años la
tasa de vacunación en la unión europea
se sitúa en el 66 por ciento
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población
y la oficina de naciones unidas para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios
lanzó su plan de asistencia global para
el año 2022 por lo que solicita a la
comunidad internacional 41 mil millones
de dólares un 17% más que este año 2021
con el fin de ayudar a 183 millones de
personas los conflictos en etiopía
mianmar y afganistán serían algunos de
los principales destinos de esta ayuda
que también busca asistir a los
colectivos más vulnerables afectados por
la pandemia y el cambio climático en
latinoamérica la onu pide 2 mil 500
millones de dólares para asistir a los
venezolanos tanto en su país como para
los que emigraron a naciones vecinas
estimamos que para 2022 habrá 274
millones de personas que necesitarán
asistencia humanitaria un 17% más que en
33 y one
y
esto es equivalente al cuarto país más
poblado del mundo nuestro objetivo a
través de este programa es ayudar a 183
millones los más vulnerables nuevamente
un aumento con respecto al año pasado
from lost share and future pues lo que
info y para ello estamos buscando un
récord de 41 mil millones de dólares
para las necesidades humanitarias del
mundo de los más necesitados en 2022 el
transit bercy tour el secretario de
estado de estados unidos anthony blinken
y el ministro ucraniano de exteriores
dmitro culeba analizaron medidas para
disuadir a rusia ante el temor de
occidente y kiev a un posible ataque
ruso contra ucrania antes de comenzar la
reunión con blinken culeba señaló que
kiev continuará mostrando moderación en
la región pese a la que llamó la
provocaciones de moscú al respecto al
ministro ruso de exteriores serguéi
lávrov advirtió del retorno a un
eventual escenario de confrontación
militar por el conflicto del este de
ucrania se prevé que blinken y lávrov se
reúna en unas horas
el ex canciller de austria sebastián
course se retira por completo de la
política el anuncio llega después de su
dimisión debido a una investigación por
supuesta corrupción curso el líder del
partido popular austriaco y canciller
hasta el pasado 9 de octubre ya informó
su decisión oficial de abandonar la
carrera política según el diario
austríaco krone la decisión del político
conservador de 35 años tendría que ver
con el reciente nacimiento de su primer
hijo
y andrew aumento de especulaciones por
el paradero y estado físico y de salud
de la tenista china peng shuai y el
comité olímpico internacional aseguró
que mantuvo una segunda videoconferencia
con ella en la que le ofreció apoyo a
cualquier nivel y también concretaron un
encuentro personal para el mes de enero
previamente de la doblete a suspendió
todos los torneos que se celebren en
china por la censura que ha rodeado este
caso después de que se denunciara abuso
sexual por parte de un ex líder del
gobierno chino ante esta decisión la
asociación de tenis china expresó su
indignación y el gobierno de beijing
reiteró una vez más su descontento con
lo que llamó una politización del
deporte
un paso firme en la defensa de las
mujeres del mundo tras la preocupación
que se mantiene por el caso peng shuai
la doble un organismo que rige el tenis
profesional femenino anunció la
cancelación de todos sus torneos en
china una decisión que había sido
advertida en el pasado por su presidente
asumiendo las consecuencias que ello
generaría no veo cómo puedo pedirle a
nuestros atletas que compitan allí
cuando a peng shuai no se le permite
comunicarse libremente y aparentemente
ha sido presionada para contradecir su
acusación de agresión sexual
benq hizo una publicación el pasado 2 de
noviembre en la red social china weibo
en la que acusó a un vice primer
ministro chino de abuso sexual tras
darse a conocer el suceso la publicación
fue borrada de internet y transcurrieron
varias semanas sin saber sobre su
paradero que generaron preocupación en
el mundo deportivo y organismos como la
onu y ongs como amnistía internacional y
gobiernos como el de eeuu la medida de
la doble-a generó diversas reacciones de
respaldo aplaudo a steve simon y a la
doble-a por adoptar una postura firme en
la defensa de los derechos humanos en
china y en todo el la w tea está en el
lado correcto de la historia al apoyar a
nuestras jugadoras gracias a la w tea
por tener el valor de enfrentarse al
partido comunista chino y suspender
todos los torneos en china desde la
desaparición de la estrella del tenis
peng shuai hasta obligar a los uigures
musulmanes a trabajar como esclavos
china comunista no respeta a la
humanidad en 2019 china albergó 8
eventos del circuito femenino de tenis
la decisión se presenta justo cuando
china se alista para recibir los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en beijing el
próximo año
el presidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández felicitó este miércoles a la
izquierdista xiomara castró virtual
presidenta electa tras los comicios
generales del 28 de noviembre en un
mensaje difundido en la cadena nacional
de radio y televisión el consejo
electoral aún no termina el conteo total
de los votos el consejo nacional
electoral ha avanzado de más de un 50%
el escrutinio presidencial y los
resultados reflejan que la señora
xiomara castró ganó las elecciones
quiero felicitarla por este medio por su
triunfo electoral y comenzaron
oficialmente las fiestas navideñas en
nuevayork el encendido del árbol de
navidad en el rockefeller center da
inicio a la temporada de fin de año el
árbol de 12 toneladas fue decorado con
más de 50.000 luces led y ya va en su
parte más alta una estrella de cristal
de la marca swarovski una multitud
participó en la ceremonia del encendido
del centro en el centro de manhattan a
diferencia del evento del año pasado
marcado restricciones por el commit 19
el árbol estará en exhibición hasta
principios de enero de 2022
con estas imágenes